remember when the globalist elite told
us that we needed a great reset of our
economy political order and really our
whole society as a result of covid well
even before covid ended the Secretary
General of the U.N had begun to argue
that the real purpose of the great reset
was not exactly to deal with the
Coronavirus but it was to fight to stop
climate change
in overcoming the pandemic we can also
avert climate cataclysm and restore our
planet
this is an epic policy test but
ultimately this is a moral test the
trillions of dollars needed for covid
recovery is money that we are borrowing
from future Generations every last penny
and we cannot use those resources to
lock in policies that burden them with a
mountain of depth on a broken Planet it
is time to flick the green switch
we have a chance not simply to reset to
all the economy but to transform it
a sustainable economy driven by
renewable energies will create new jobs
in the infrastructure and the resilience
future
and an inclusive worlds will help ensure
that people can enjoy Better Health and
the full respect of their human rights
and live with dignity on a healthy
planet
coffee's recovery and our planet's
repair must be the two sides of the same
coin now you might be wondering how did
covid policy become climate policy well
the same way that inflation policy
became climate policy you remember that
when the Biden Administration pushed his
inflation reduction Act only to admit
immediately after its passing that the
bill wasn't really about inflation
inflation which it didn't alleviate and
probably made worse but instead about
fighting climate change well just
yesterday the U.N Secretary General
explained that the reason the covid
policy is now about climate change is
because everything is about climate
change he lets that little fact slip
with one word
biblical
rising sea levels combined with the Deep
intrusion of salt water will make large
parts of their huge Deltas simply an
inevitable
we see similar threats in the Mekong
Delta and Beyond
the consequences of all of these are
unthinkable
low-lying communities and the entire
countries could disappear forever
we would witness a mass Exodus of entire
populations on a Biblical scale
biblical scale
kind of a funny phrase for a globalist
elite that openly mocks religion the
traditional moral order even the
existence of God
but it makes sense when you realize that
to a materialist climate is literally
everything
it's all the stuff there is when
religious politicians want to push some
policy or another they tend to invoke
God the Ten Commandments the natural law
these modern secular globalist
politicians can't do that but they still
want to wield power and so their
arguments transform into weird
superstitions about the weather claims
that are just as apocalyptic as any
religiously motivated political movement
in history the only difference is that
while the old-timey religious
politicians have traditionally been
constrained by the fear of God these
people have nothing holding them back in
principle from wielding whatever power
they want I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
back to the show uh later on in the show
we have a really important interview you
know that I think that pretty much only
one news story matters right now and it
happens to be the story that the
establishment media will not talk about
that is the Environmental catastrophe in
Ohio the the train that derailed and
sent a ton of poison all up into the air
in East Palestine Ohio we've got Lindsey
Johnston who is a wife and mother of two
daughters who lives in the one mile
evacuation Zone in East Palestine so
because unfortunately the residents of
East Palestine are not getting very much
air time right now and Pete Buda judge
and Joe Biden are trying to just blow
past this whole thing we will have her
on the show a little bit later my
favorite comment yesterday is from Frank
s who says Chelsea handlers life without
kids is so great that she had to make up
90 of her day great observation
in her video which was supposed to be
funny I guess she says I'm childless so
I wake up in the morning then I go right
back to bed and then I pleasure myself
and she goes through some kind of normal
things and then it becomes very quickly
Fantastical and she says then I go to
Paris and I kill Hitler and then I do
this and I do that and the the joke here
I don't know if she really intended this
is that all the people who say that they
don't want to have kids and they don't
want a family because they just want to
amuse themselves all day long
don't have all that much to do the the
Millennials who say oh no we don't want
kids we want to go have brunch there's
only so much brunch you can eat okay
brunch goes for like an hour and a half
or two hours what are you gonna do with
the rest of your day what are you going
to do with the rest of your life
if you want to just amuse yourself all
the time George Bernard Shaw famously
said that hell is the place where you
have nothing to do but amuse yourself we
got to go do stuff when you gotta go do
stuff you've got to have some energy and
some Focus that's why you got to check
out Black Rifle coffee right now go to
Black riflecoffee.com use promo code
Knowles Black Rifle coffee is fueling
Americans before they go out and do epic
things with their lives led by a team of
military veterans the guys at Black
Rifle coffee are hyper focused and Hyper
Vigilant in everything they do lucky for
you they are obsessed with making great
coffee because every great adventure
starts with a great cup of coffee they
serve great coffee to folks who love
America and that's the start and end of
it more than just making great coffee
Black Rifle coffee's missionary goal is
to give back to Americans who have
fought and are fighting for freedom in
this country they want to sell enough
premium coffee to be able to build a
support network for veterans First
Responders and along enforcement if you
want to support this incredible company
go to blackriflecoffee.com use promo
code Knolls at checkout for 10 off your
purchase and your first coffee Club
order the coffee is one of a kind but
it's your support it gets gear funding
and supplies into the hands of those on
our front lines go to Black
riflecoffee.com promo code knows get 10
off you can also find Black Rifle coffee
in grocery and convenience stores near
you Black Rifle coffee Americas coffee
speaking of One World Government
speaking of the United Nations and the
Great resetters and the globalists
trying to take all of our political
power away Elon Musk just showed up to
the world government Summit and used his
appearance as an opportunity to attack
the very idea
of world government one thing I should
say and I know this is called the world
government Summit
um but I think we should be maybe a
little bit concerned about uh actually
becoming too much of a single World
Government
um if I may say that we want to avoid
creating a civilizational risk by having
um frankly this may sound a little odd
too much a cooperation between
governments
um you know if you know if you look at
say the history and the rise and fall of
civilizations
um that really all throughout history
civilizations have risen in Poland but
it hasn't meant the Doom of humanity as
a whole because they've been they've
been all these separate civilizations
that were separated by great distances
and so
um you know say like while Rome was
falling it you know Islam was rising and
uh so you had like a
uh you know the the sort of caliphate
doing incredibly well while Rome was
doing terribly
um and that actually ended up being a
source of preservation of knowledge and
uh and many as scientific advancements
love it Elon every day more and more
shows that he is he is the people's
billionaire he actually is doing things
that matter politically to take power
back from this crooked leftist globalist
Elite he's doing it in the big Tech
sector obviously he cracked the Monopoly
of the libs on big Tech and through
Twitter and then release the Twitter
files and brought some transparency now
he's making really important points at
the One World Government Summit
you know that I am no small government
conservative I don't think the founding
fathers were small government
conservatives I think the idea of a
small government in a country of 330
million people that spans from sea to
shiny scene has an Empire overseas is
laughable and it's never happened
anywhere and it will never happen in
real life but I am a strong proponent of
limited government
I I want government to be confined to
its proper limits and what these
globalists what the great resetters what
the one world government type Elites one
is no limits whatsoever
it's amazing that we look back on forms
of government from the 17th century from
the 16th century and we say oh that was
terrible it was that that it was so
backwards you had in those centuries you
had monarchies in fact you had Divine
Right monarchies who believed that they
had a right from God to rule their
Nations
Divine Right monarchs claimed much less
power than our current globalist Elites
because Divine Right monarchs at least
were believed that they were held in
check by God they were accountable to
somebody and they were quite accountable
to somebody because if they acted in a
way that was unjust
they were going to roast for eternity
our current globalist Elites they don't
believe that their power to rule comes
from God they don't believe in God
they don't think they're accountable at
all they think their power to rule comes
from their ability to get that power and
they've done a bang-up job of taking
power away from you in recent years
and so there are no limits in principle
to what they will do
Divine Right monarchs at least
appreciated the principle of
subsidiarity
the the Emperors the Holy Roman emperors
the the emperor's threat history at
least recognized the principle of
subsidiarity that you would have
decisions made at the most local level
possible where those decisions could be
made with competence were where power
could be exercised with confidence and
then if it couldn't at a more local
level then you'd bring up to another
level and another level on another level
we have that here in America we call it
federalism you make decisions at the
Town level then at the state the county
maybe then at the state then and only
then at the national level at least that
was the idea that our country was
founded on
that seems to have gone away as this
liberal globalist Elite that wants more
and more power at higher and higher
levels has taken over
this is a big threat
and and very few people are standing up
against it very few people who at least
could be invited to these sorts of
events or standing up against it Elon
Musk happens to be one of them now
speaking of governing the world
the U.S Diplomat who's sent to
Afghanistan
uh has obviously her work cut out for
her a lot of problems in Afghanistan and
she has decided that
there's one special tool that she can
offer to the women of Afghanistan to
help alleviate their plight
which we'll get to in one second first
though do you have a will you should if
you don't you gotta check out epic will
right now go to epicwill.com use promo
code Knowles recent surveys have
revealed that 100 of people will die at
some point in their life this is what
the studies show I cannot stress enough
how important it is to write a will and
epic will is here to get you started a
will is not just for the elderly or for
people with a room full of valuable
Collectibles a will is about leaving
behind your legacy having your voice
heard when you can't speak for yourself
and being there for your loved ones even
after you are gone for just 119 bucks
and in as little as five minutes epic
will can help you create your last will
and testament living will and even
Health Care power of attorney there's
step-by-step online form makes it super
duper easy all you've got to do is fill
in the blanks fifty percent of Americans
don't have a will do not just be another
statistic I I waited way too long to put
my will together I now feel much more
secure about what's going to happen to
my money and my stuff and most
importantly my kids go to epicwill.com
use promo code Knowles to save 10 on
Epic Will's complete will package that
is epicwill.com promo code Knowles Karen
Decker the charge Affair of the U.S
mission to Afghanistan this is the top
Diplomat that we have in Afghanistan
uh Karen Decker recognizes that afghans
and especially Afghan women have a lot
of challenges right now and so she's
she's offering them
some
suggestions on how to improve their
lives
she tweets quote
are Afghans familiar with hashtag black
girl magic
and the movement it inspired
do Afghan girls need a similar movement
what about Afghan women teach me ready
to learn
#black History Month
at Beyonce at lizzo at Regina King I
don't know who Regina King is
Afghan women
come up to the Embassy or consulate or
whatever the US has in Afghanistan they
say please
can we have bread can we have money can
we not be terrorized by the Taliban can
you give us guns Italy can you give us
and
Karen Decker stands there she goes I
think the best I can do is a tweet about
black girl magic have you checked out
black girl magic oh yeah that you don't
know forget about money and guns and
food and opportunities and power and no
no you what you need is
black girl magic I don't know what black
girl magic is I certainly don't possess
any of it I'm not familiar with the
movement that it inspired I'm skeptical
that any such movement exists
and I am totally convinced that black
girl magic will not solve the problems
that Afghan women face I'm not sure that
anything will solve the political
problems Afghan women face but certainly
not black girl magic I don't think a
Black History Month will solve their
problems and I don't think even Beyonce
will solve their problems this is not
the first crazy tweet that Karen Decker
has sent out
uh Karen Decker tweeted out not that
long ago quote in 1960 four black
students ordered coffee at a diner in
Greensboro North Carolina they were
refused service but they would not leave
they came back the next day and a sit-in
movement was born has non-violent
protest ever been successful in
Afghanistan why or why not hashtag Black
History Month I'll answer Karen's
question there no non-violent protest
has never been successful in Afghanistan
because if you engaged in a non-violent
protest if you went into the Woolworths
of Afghanistan and sat down at the lunch
counter the Taliban would cut your head
off that's why and that didn't happen
here in America because America is a
Christian country or at the very least
it was and America is Western and comes
from a civilization that is animated by
Christianity and that's different than a
civilization animated by Islam and
because America has a tradition that
beginning in the 18th Century starts to
become a little bit more liberal and by
the 20th century it becomes quite
liberal and the sort of non-violent
sit-ins that Karen Decker is referring
to here would have some political effect
in America whereas in Afghanistan they
wouldn't do a damn thing and black
history month isn't going to help in any
way to alleviate the blight of Afghan
people these these these American Libs
oh my goodness gracious every time an
American Diplomat sends out a tweet I
become about 25 percent more
isolationist I'm not isolationist by
nature but every time I see some of this
cringe-inducing nonsense this liberal
piffle clap draft I I want to pull my
hair out and I want to build a gigantic
wall all around the continental United
States and I want to just divorce our
country from the rest of the world so
embarrassing is this nonsense
it tells you something though it's not
just that Karen Decker is crazy and
silly and absurd it's no that's not the
issue
she is articulating the beliefs of the
liberal Elites who controlled our
country
it's deeply unserious it's absurd to try
to apply these lessons to Afghanistan we
tried it for 20 years it didn't work
hence the the problems that Afghanistan
is in right now
but what what is she articulating what
she is articulating is the slogans of
the civil rights movement and pretending
that these slogans of the 1960s civil
rights movement in America will apply to
the entire world
it won't and why why does everything
seem to come back to the Civil Rights
Movement
we talk about gay issues we talk about
bathrooms we talk about women we even
when we talk about conservatives even
when we talk about even when you talk
about traditional American ideas for
some reason it's always seems to be
framed through the lens of the Civil
Rights Movement this is the new Civil
Rights Movement even when we talk about
the Second Amendment we say well this is
really about civil rights and it's a
kind of a new iteration of the Civil
Rights Movement why well the reason is
that the Civil Rights Movement was so
successful that it is essentially the
Constitution that we have been living
under for the past 60 years this was the
thesis of a book by Christopher Caldwell
the age of entitlement really really
great book which argues that we now have
two constitutions in America we've got
the original one the U.S Constitution
you know the one on parchment with the
silly handwriting and then we've got
another one which was the the civil
rights constitution from the 1960s and
those two things are in conflict with
one another certainly on the matter of
freedom of Association but on another
number of other matters too and and his
argument is that all of the the major
constitutional conflicts that we've been
dealing with since then
are a result of the discrepancies
between these two rather different
constitutions that we are simultaneously
attempting to live under
and now apparently to export overseas
black girl magic I don't know I don't
know I don't think it's going to help
the women in Kabul speaking of black
people the Georgia state senator
Emmanuel Jones just highlighted the
the deep unseriousness but but political
Danger of of this new kind of liberal
activism in a way that's kind of banal
and we've all heard it before but but
his explanation tells you a lot about it
this guy state senator Jones called
Clarence Thomas you're going to be
shocked to hear it and Uncle Tom
place the statue of Clarence Thomas on
this grounds
we cannot avoid that conversation so I'm
not going to avoid it either
in the black community we have an
expression
and I don't want to use this label to
deeply hear because I'm just trying to
tell you what we have in
African-American Community when we talk
about a person of color
that goes back historically the days of
slavery and that person betraying his
own Community we have a term in the
black community
that term that we use is called Uncle
Tom
and Uncle Tom is a either fictional or
non-fictional character I don't really
know the origin of Uncle Tom but it
talks about a person who back during the
days of slavery sold his soul to the
slave masters
this Clarence Thomas he's an Uncle Tom
and what's an Uncle Tom it's either a
fictional or a non-fictional you know
come to think of it I have no idea who
the hell Uncle Tom is but I'm going to
call Clarence Thomas one because I don't
like him
that sums it up perfectly
it sums it all up
hey I don't have any idea what I'm
talking about but screw you Clarence
Thomas that's those are the attacks
generally on Clarence Thomas and on most
conservatives
but it shows you something that I have
been yelling about for years and wrote a
whole book about that became a number
one National bestseller speechless
controlling words controlling minds and
that we've got to pay a lot of attention
to
idioms crop up
that people often use unthinkingly
this guy is using the idiom Uncle Tom
unthinkingly he doesn't know what it
means
but that that happens for a lot of us
all the time
let there be light forbidden fruit am I
My Brother's Keeper fire and brimstone
the blind leading the blind go the extra
mile
all of those idioms come from the Bible
most people don't know that they come
from the Bible
in in fact many people who have never
read the Bible
who don't believe in the Bible will use
those idioms all the time that's that's
how culture works it culture works by
certain texts by certain pieces of art
by certain rituals just creeping in and
not only becoming and not only being
inserted into your language but actually
coming to constitute your language and
by constituting your language it
constitutes the way that you think and
that's what you're seeing here
with Uncle Tom
this guy has no idea what the the
context of Uncle Tom is he just knows
that Uncle Tom means black people aren't
supposed to be conservative that's what
he knows about Uncle Tom and so he just
says it beep boop he's not thinking this
is not a particularly conscious human
being but he's just saying
Clarence Thomas he's Republican he's a
conservative bad Uncle Tom it's wrong
you got to vote Democrat dude
and that's how culture works and the
libs have done a very very good job and
as they are pushing the Bible out of our
culture as they're pushing the Bible out
of schools they're pushing these idioms
they're pushing these ways of thinking
they're pushing this language out of our
head that's why they're so obsessed
about doing that that's why they're so
obsessed about putting the weird gay
porn and the weird liberal
intersectionist texts into the schools
the reason they're doing that is not so
you can learn some lesson
about a racial hierarchy I mean that's a
that's a secondary effect that they like
but it's more so that your brain just
becomes shaped and filled with these
this kind of language these kinds of
images and so you will unthinkingly
carry out their plans you won't even
know that you're doing it you know the
European Union officially enacted a
statute
that allows food producers to
incorporate Cricket powder into its
flower-based products not because it
tastes better but because the political
Elites have deemed that eating the bugs
is better for the environment so right
down to the food that you eat the world
wants to make you woke but not Dennis
Prager he wants to make you wise and the
founder of prageru is going to do just
that with a never-before-seen series
exclusively on daily wire plus called
The Master's program with Dennis Prager
Dennis is a mentor with a wealth of
experience
what the master's program aims to do is
take 40 Years of wisdom and experience
from one of the most influential
conservative thinkers in America today
and distill it all down to its Essence
he covers such topics as the
consequences of secularism and is human
nature basically good it's as thought
provoking as it is Illuminating a brand
new episode of prageru's Masters program
is available to stream right now
exclusively on daily wire plus so head
on over to dailywireplus.com
become a member watch prageru's master's
program and much more dailywearplus.com
today also you may have heard me mention
that we're celebrating the our president
is for sale sale over here at the daily
wire did you know that right now we're
dailywire.com shop you can get up to 40
percent off on great stuff including
Smokey Mike and the god king Nostradamus
and Chef house lines from my collection
don't wait on taking advantage of the
sale go to dailywired.com shop today
now speaking of actual political
tokenism
China is attacking Pete butterjudge when
I see China attacking Pete butterjudge
I'm reminded of the iran-iraq war in
which I want both sides to lose I want
the war to be drawn out as long as
possible and I want both sides to lose
China through its propaganda Outlet the
global times
is attacking Buddha judge over that
train incident in Ohio that spewed all
the poison into the air we'll be
speaking with a resident from East
Palestine Ohio momentarily
they're attacking people to judge it and
they say
instead of fixing these problems Federal
Regulators have mulled a proposal backed
by the rail Lobby that would weaken
existing brake safety rules notably
Buddha judge does not have any
experience in transportation and was
essentially a vanity political appointee
by the administration of President Joe
Biden to help boost his political score
the secretary faced scrutiny recently on
and on and on
I mentioned this because
shows you something about propaganda
Global times is a state Chinese
propaganda Outlet
they're attacking Pete bootage Edge over
the Ohio incident to distract from the
Spy balloon incident in China sending a
bunch of surveillance over our country
but the charge is that Pete Buddha judge
is a vanity political appointee in over
his head manifestly not capable of doing
the job who was only chosen because it
helped to boost Joe Biden's political
score because mayor Pete has some appeal
to the Democrat base and he's gay and he
ran for president and so they just put
him in there
that is obviously true
the best propaganda
is true we always think of propaganda as
being dishonest as being lies so
sometimes that's the case the big lie is
propaganda sometimes which is a
misunderstood phrase ironically it is a
phrase
used by the Nazis to accuse the Jews of
telling a lie and now the Democrats use
that phrase to call the Republicans
Nazis without recognizing that in their
very use of the phrase that the
Democrats are putting themselves in the
in the very same place as the Nazis
either way it's neither here nor there
some propaganda is dishonest and lies
the best propaganda is true
and the propaganda China just put out
about mayor Pete happens to be true
speaking of propaganda
New York Times right now has an op-ed
called Steve Bennett's podcast is top
misinformation spreader study says a
large podcast study found that Mr
bannon's war room had more falsehoods
and unsubstantiated claims than other
political talk shows so
this story
is a New York Times article about a
story that we covered on the show last
week and the story that we covered on
the show last week was a story about me
because it was a study that came out of
the Brookings institution that opened up
with a quote from me in which I on the
show with Senator Cruz said that uh
podcasts are the place where you can say
whatever you want
opens up with two or three paragraphs
about me and this interaction and about
how conservatives lie on podcasts then
the rest of the study goes on and says
conservatives lie something like 11
times more than Democrats lie on
podcasts and so I was looking at that
study from Brookings
and I pointed it out on the show I
looked at just some of their most basic
data points and I realized they were
totally bogus one of the little graphs
they had there was about the number of
episodes that podcasters have produced
and it had I think all of the daily wire
shows were listed there and I I was
looking and I noticed that it said that
Drew and Matt had produced more episodes
of their podcasts than I had not that
the episodes were more highly rated not
that the episodes were more conservative
not that the episodes told more lies no
it was just simply about the number of
episodes produced
and I looked at that and I said I know
that's not true
I went to the Daily wire website I look
at episode number and I realized I I
have more episode numbers than Drew and
Matt do
simply because now Drew is once a week
and Matt's show started after my show
did so that's that's why I would have
more episodes I said wait a second so
they got that number wrong I looked I
said when did they start collecting data
for this or stop collecting data I
looked I said it was a year ago somebody
said okay well Drew I guess then because
this show wasn't only once a week but so
maybe that doesn't matter but then even
a year ago I still had substantially
more episodes out than Matt did and yet
the graph said that Matt had
substantially more episodes out than I
did
all of which is to say the data in that
study
were Bogus the data weren't true forget
about how they measured disinformation
spread in podcasts
the way that they measure that was by
going to left-wing fact checking Outlets
which are really just left-wing opinion
Outlets but they try to have this patina
of credibility so they say well
uh we fact Checkers hold on I've got to
take off my DNC t-shirt and put on my
fact Checker t-shirt okay I'm a fact
Checker and I'm gonna say that when
those Republicans said that the
Democrats are bad that's a 10 pinocchios
that's a total lie and okay now I'm
going to go over here and I'm going to
put my uh calculator statistician hat on
and I'm going to punch in a bunch of
numbers and they're going to be totally
bogus even on the on the most basic
level of who who is producing X number
of podcasts and then I'm going to put it
here in this nice survey from a
left-wing Think Tank called Brookings
and then okay here's our study and then
what happens the New York Times and
these are all the same Liars The New
York Times goes in they say well we've
got this study now so we're going to
publish this article and the article is
that Republicans are big fat Liars
that's it that's the process
the process is you start with a leftist
activist who says I think Republicans
are big fat liars and then you launder
that impulse through bogus statisticians
bogus fact Checkers and a bogus news
Outlet called The New York Times all
staffed by the exact same leftist
activists
and you say well this is very
authoritative and scientific
and the our scientific authoritative
white lab coat brilliant PhD credential
conclusion is Republicans are big fat
liars I hate them
this bogus total propagate very
dishonest propaganda too that is however
how fake news becomes established
that's it that's the process
and it happens all the time I just
happened to notice this one a little
more clearly because it involved
something that
involved me
and that I knew just immediately was
false
but this happens every day this happens
every day and if you were still
believing these people I don't know that
I can help you
speaking of political campaigns Nikki
Haley has formally kicked off her
residential campaign she had released a
video some days ago saying I'm going to
run for president she just held her
first rally and here is the campaign
message
I have always had a deep belief in
America
but I know America is better than all
the
all the distractions that we have today
and I'm confident that the American
people agree
we're ready
ready to move past the stale ideas and
Faded names of the past
and we are more than ready for a new
generation to lead us into the future
okay what is Nikki doing here in this
launch
she's opening up with a great dig at Joe
Biden
not a direct dig but a pretty clear dick
she says we're ready to move past the
stale old desiccated names of the past
so it's obviously a dig at bite and
Biden's been in politics for over 50
years National politics for over 50
years
it's a bit of a dig at Trump
we'll use a name from the past he was
President starting in 2017.
that was a long time ago okay
it's a dig at Trump
to dig it maybe some of the other
candidates
and it's doubling down on
Nikki Haley's Centrist cred
Nikki Haley has gotten some Bona fides
in lots of different areas of the right
she worked for Trump
she put her hand up at the U.N and she
stood up against the bad guys she
also was more moderate and conciliatory
when she was a governor of South
Carolina
she can talk very tough she can also be
a little more moderate in Her speech
which side is she going to run on
she's picking the center length
as she has to she's not going to run to
the right of trump
very few people can run to the right of
trump DeSantis is attempting to run to
the right of trump right now and is
being fairly successful at it
Nikki Haley is not going to run to the
right of those guys if you get a Ted
Cruz in the race if you get a Josh
Hawley in the race
Nikki Haley is not going to run to the
right of them and so I think she very
wisely is saying no I'm going to run
more of a Centrist campaign and the
proof of this is
that her campaign messages we're going
to move beyond the past
which is the sort of thing that a lot of
politicians say but if you're running a
Centrist campaign it carries even more
significance the the super right-wing
conservative campaign slogan would be
returned to the Past return with a V
instead of a u you know return to
tradition
the the conservative campaign slogan
would be we're going to look to the past
and take the wisdom of the past and
bring it into the present and and launch
It Forward into the future we're going
to draw on the best of our tradition and
then we're gonna we're gonna bring that
forward
the center right
to kind of more moderate even say
classical liberal campaign slogan is I
forget about the past the past is the
past and we're in the present we're
going to look toward the future
that is that is going to be Nikki
Haley's campaign slogan I know a lot of
conservatives aren't going to like that
very much but I do think that that line
has some appeal
I think that the the number of
birkian conservatives wearing Tweed and
looking back to the Glorious Days of the
Holy Roman Empire is a relatively small
number of Americans and so Nikki Haley
is making a really mainstream play the
question is can that message resonate in
the primary where the conservatives have
a lot more say
I'm not so sure but I still don't think
it's a mistake for her not to run
further to the right
people need to to know their Lane right
now the lane she's running in is pretty
wide open
the right wing Lane is getting very
crowded with very very big personalities
speaking of politicians
speaking of
speaking of the center and the right
kind of moving moving so far to the left
now that the the hard strong right wing
position is that men are not women and
women are not men Arkansas state senator
Matt McKee is under Fire right now for
grilling a transgender Witness
it's a dude dressed up as a chick
and he asked this man a question that
you are no longer allowed to ask the
transgender people
are you telling us that you're
unfamiliar with a large body of medical
evidence of the harm that has come upon
the people that have gone through these
processes I've been married with a large
body of evidence that shows that
providing good affirming care saves
lives are you saying that you're unaware
of the large body of medical evidence of
the harm that has come upon these people
in these processes have been gone
through how are you unaware of that body
of evidence I will repeat what I just
said are you unaware of that repeat what
I just said you said that you're a trans
woman I trans female yes sir do you have
a penis oh
yes
that's horrible you're the one you're
the one that brought that into the
discussion you're the one who never said
anything about genitalia oh yeah
everything that's horrible how dare you
ask the
why is that so bad
I I remember this was a big deal when
some confused man went on a talk show I
think it was Laverne Cox I don't
whatever his real name is from Orange is
the New Black and he went on one of the
network talk shows and the interviewer
said do you have
do you still have your do you still have
the goods and this was so shocking
Hunter you can't ask this person that
question
why not
the Crux of a lot of opposition to
transgenderism don't forget 80
opposition in America to transgenderism
specifically as it applies to kids
hinges on the idea that dudes can go
into the girl's locker room and get
naked so whether or not a person has
their genitals is a pivotal question
here
how dare you ask that question good on
this guy Matt McKee I hope that a lot of
conservatives take this lesson and and
not only don't run away from the the
left wing oh my goodness clutching my
pearls I hope they actively seek it out
I hope that in every one of these
testimonies
about the transgender issue I hope that
the conservatives ask this question
seek it out this is a winning issue for
us
and the the more that the radical
pro-trans people in the room start
screaming like Banshees
the the more the normal sane people are
going to be convinced that they are
right about this issue keep it up good
job state senator Matt McKee I really
wanted to get to the crane and Company
will Thomas Leah Thomas story today they
had an explosive interview about that
that swimmer the big giant dude who
swims on the girls team and takes the
trophies away from all the girls at
UPenn but we don't have time to do that
we've got to get to a more important
story I think so we'll get to that
tomorrow if you haven't watched the
cranico interview on this though make
sure you go check out that interview
today
because right now we turn our attention
away from
the seemingly perennial political issues
of the transgender agenda
the radical cultural agenda even the
great reset agenda
we turn now to a major news story that
is not getting nearly enough attention
in Ohio
this would be the train derailment that
sent a vinyl chloride and a number of
other very very dangerous chemicals up
into the atmosphere local officials
burned this stuff off it put phosphine
into the air that was poison gas from
World War One put hydrochloric acid into
the air it killed a lot of animals in
the town it caused an evacuation though
now the authorities are saying oh that's
okay it's not a big deal everything's
fine don't worry about your water don't
worry about your air quality come on
back here let's get those news cameras
out of Ohio and let's go back to normal
well if that's the case how come we
aren't hearing from people in the town
itself we will do that today with
Lindsay Johnston a 26 year old wife and
mother of two daughters who lives in the
one mile evacuation Zone in East
Palestine Ohio Lindsay very sorry what
happened to your town and thank you for
coming on the show
thank you for having me Michael so
Lindsay
before we get to the reaction
what happened as you and your neighbors
have seen it
um so my husband and I were actually we
were out of town just um a few miles up
north when it happened and when we're on
our way back we had a bunch of people
texting us you know are you guys okay
what's going on up there
and we hadn't heard anything about it
yet
um
so we got we got home and we had been
like watching things on the news and we
just started packing immediately
um I don't think it was until
later that they came around they came
around with um speakers and their cars
saying you know you should evacuate but
at that point it wasn't mandatory yet
um but we did leave that night
um
so we've been in we've been out
for I think 12 13 days now
um
but I mean as of right now they say that
it is safe for us to return home
um they you know February 6th they were
saying that there was
um the wines words were we were facing
grave danger of death
um they were threatening child
endangerment charges to anybody that did
stay behind if they had children with
them and then two days later they said
it's absolutely safe to go home
how on Earth are they going to reconcile
those two statements I mean we we've
seen news reports that say oh there's no
big deal there's no health risk not even
to your animals we've we're testing the
air we're testing the water and then you
see the pictures and the videos of
people who who are looking at all of
their chickens lying dead whose animals
have died obviously there's poison
everywhere how is how is all that poison
just cleared out of town poison that
could have killed your children if you
spent the night there how could that
possibly clear out of town in 48 hours
right exactly those are exactly our
thoughts um we know that there are some
people that have returned
um and have gotten sick I know our
neighbors went home for a day and they
um
I think they and their one of their
children broke out in a rash had
scratchy throats I went back for just a
half an hour to get some stuff from our
house and I left with a scratchy throat
um my husband's been at our house a few
times to clean
um and he said that for the last three
days he's been having trouble breathing
um
yeah it's I mean they've found at least
3 500 dead fish in the streams
and I mean all the time on you know our
East Palestine Facebook groups and
things their people are posting pictures
of their animals and dead animals that
they find with no you know indication of
trauma or anything
um they're just dead with no explanation
how far out of town have you evacuated
um right now we are in Negley um which
is just the next town over we're on the
far end of Negley um with my mom
um we had been we'd been probably a half
an hour out of town before that
um we were in two separate hotels like
going from different places and stuff
trying to figure stuff out but
um I know this is you know for a lot of
people in town
it's hard to manage this it's hard to
afford nobody planned for this to have
to spend two weeks in a hotel room and
I'm sure plenty of people are also
thinking okay you go one town over you
go Two Towns over well we've just talked
about an historic chemical explosion
it's not as though yeah you know these
places are going to be unaffected as
well what are the authorities doing and
saying in town
um I mean
you know there was a there was a town
hall meeting last night
um
and
our mayor has said you know that he's
fed up as well
um but we're really not
seeing a lot happening
um
I I feel like we're not holding Norfolk
as accountable as we should be
um they rebuilt the railroad before the
evacuation was even lifted they rebuilt
it over contaminated soil
and
you know it's mostly the help is coming
from local organizations getting
together donating water donating you
know things to people that need it
um sending food to the hotels where
there are a lot of residents
um but I mean
their official statements are it's safe
to return home the water is safe to
drink but I mean even Mike dewine said
that he would be drinking bottled water
um of course you know and he said that
he would return home but I think that he
would also have the financial ability to
get you know private testing done
instead of the testing that's being
contracted out by Norfolk Southern
this seems to be the biggest
environmental disaster on U.S soil in
probably in my lifetime I mean you think
about maybe 911 or you know a major
terror attack uh accepted in terms of
just an actual accident environmental
catastrophe you know clogging up the air
in the water I haven't seen anything
like it
where's the federal government I assume
Transportation secretary Pete Buda judge
hasn't come by I know that President
Biden hasn't have you seen anything from
the federal government
well our county is uh
uh in in the last election our County
voted 71 Republican so I uh I kind of
feel like maybe we're not that important
to the federal government
wow and especially with all the language
about the flyover country and the
deplorables and the irredeemables and
let small town America die yeah it's no
surprise I'm not surprised that East
Palestine has been completely overlooked
by the Biden Administration by The
Establishment media by pretty much
everybody but
once this news story goes away as the
people who write our news are trying to
do more and more so by the hour you're
still going to have to live there this
is where your homes are that this this
Whole Town's going to have to live with
this and we can hear that the air is
safe and the water safe nobody actually
believes that you're telling me that
your neighbors and even your husband are
experiencing this is not safe they are
getting sick when they go back to clean
the home so it's obviously just a
complete Croc that's coming from the
authorities and it's going to go on for
years and so what's going to happen you
live in this town for five years 10
years 20 years
what what consequences are you going to
have to deal with that the railroad
isn't going to have to deal with that
the government's not going to have to
deal with that everybody is just going
to look past it's a really really awful
situation I guess the the only thing we
can do is call some attention to it and
demand that the government do a damn
thing about it
yeah yeah
um I mean we're all concerned of what
you know what health issues we might all
experience down the line and I mean our
home values who who's going to buy who
if we decide to move away right what are
we going to do who's going to buy
um you know it's people can't
if they're homeowners they can't just up
and leave if you rent it might be a
little bit easier for you but you know
we own our home and so what are we
supposed to do how are we supposed to
you know avoid this when we don't know
what's going to happen in the future and
we don't believe what they're telling us
right and and rightly so you there's no
reason that you should believe what
they're telling you in fact your own
experience is proving that what they're
saying is not true Lindsay we'll have to
leave it there you will be in our
prayers as will everybody in East
Palestine and I hope that there is a
little more political help that comes
your way uh from the people who are who
are absolutely overlooking you and the
rest of the people in your community
right now uh Lindsey Johnson thanks so
much for coming on the show thank you
the rest of the show continues now we
actually have another great person to
talk to I talked I mentioned him on the
show
earlier uh this is the guy who spoke
truth to power this one conservative guy
in that Vice documentary
all the libs clutching their pearls was
just a marvelous performance
that will be on the member block you
don't want to miss it go to
dailywire.com Knowles use code Knowles
at checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
foreign